well turning now to the middle east five
people were killed in a new attack in
israel extending the country's worst
outbreak of violence in years police say
they killed the gunman who shot those
people last night he's identified as a
palestinian from the west bank israeli
forces there have arrested five other
suspects and as roxanna seberry reports
this series of killings is raising new
concerns ahead of next month's important
religious holidays
video aired on israeli tv appears to
show the gunman firing an assault rifle
at a bicyclist who races away then
shouting at a passing driver to stop
opening fire and causing the car to
crash
israeli police say the shooter drove on
to another nearby location police
who
found him
shot him killed him and stopped this
massacre he left behind five victims and
scenes of chaos and anger the attack in
an ultra-orthodox tel aviv suburb was
the fifth and deadliest attack in israel
in less than two weeks israeli
authorities say the last two were
carried out by arab israelis inspired by
the islamic state
the violence has intensified fears that
next month when muslim jewish and
christian holidays converge tensions
will rise even more
neither the islamic state nor
palestinian militant groups have claimed
responsibility for last night's attack
and though some palestinians celebrated
in the west bank village home to the
gunman palestinian authority president
mahmoud abbas has condemned the killings
for cbs mornings roxanna seberry london